bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
votre journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité à ce soir ces images de
commandes des milliers personnes se sont
mobilisées dans les rues de la ville
c'est dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo une manifestation
de colère a dirigé contre le président
rwandais paul kagame a accusé par
l'armée congolaise de crimes de guerre
le chercheur égale numérique est
l'invité de ce journal
un vin de fer est désormais engagé entre
londres et la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme la juridiction a fait annuler
l'expulsion plusieurs personnes en
situation irrégulière
l avion spécialement affrété toujours
cloués au sol
et puis les contours d'un accord se
dessine avec tel-aviv et le caire israël
prêt à exporter son gaz vers l'europe en
le faisant transiter par l'egypte
objectif contourner le chantage au gaz
imposé par le kremlin
ils sont des milliers à avoir investi
les rues de goma ce mercredi des hommes
essentiellement qui ont fait route vers
la frontière avec le rwanda ils ont
d'ailleurs tenté de forcer le passage l
état voisin accusé de soutenir de
financer et d'armer le m23 à kigali de
son côté dément tout soutien au
mouvement rebelle charles ici bas
il court vers la frontière le rwanda
n'est qu'à 200 mètres et ses hommes
aimeraient bien s'y rendre pour eux
kigali héberge et soutient la rébellion
du m23 celle qui mène des attaques dans
leur région et qui s'empare de
territoire jamal al-hai qu'on nous
laisse rentrer au rwanda nous n'allons
pas nous battre nous voulons juste
montrer à kagame qu'il nous fait
souffrir
a béni les congolais sont massacrés et
ici on veut nous terroriser nous disons
non ça ne doit pas se passer comme ça
l'armée arrête les manifestants à
quelques mètres du point de passage mais
dit partager leur colère le rwanda ne
nous aime pas il ne fait pas peur et
nous allons le combattre s'ils veulent
la guerre il aura guère
pour le moment nous vous remercions pour
vos actions nous vous demandons à
manifester pacifiquement
rébellion un dominante tutsie le m23
vaincu en 2013 reprend les armes fin
2021 lundi les rebelles s'emparent d'un
territoire plus au nord à bunagana
vendredi deux petits enfants sont tués
dans le bombardement de leur école lors
de combats entre le m23 et l'armée
congolaise cette semaine le gouvernement
hausse le ton contre kigali qui
l'accusent d'avoir participé au
financement et à l'armement des rebelles
le gouvernement rwandais dément toute
participation au combat ou soutien au
m23
très reagan me verrez notre invité
bonsoir à vous vous êtes chercheur au
baromètre sécuritaire du kivu merci
d'avoir accepté l'invitation de france
24 une première réaction après avoir
visionné ce sujet les rwandais installés
au à goma ont-ils des raisons
s'inquiéter lorsque l'on voit que
certains commerces appartenant à des
rondes et ont été directement pris pour
cible
[Musique]
quelques dérapages
ja oui même des discours qui sont
condamnables mais
j'espère en tout cas que ça ne va pas de
générer et peut-être comme c'était à
l'occasion de ces manifestations qui
nous paraît qu'ils nouveau pareil c'est
aussi dommage je pense que la situation
pourra rentrer dans l'ordre est ce que
dans ce conflit qui oppose kinshasa et
kigali ce qu'on peut imaginer un seul
instant que l'ambassadeur vincent karega
puisse être expulsés comme le réclame la
rue à goma notamment depuis plusieurs
jours
oui je pense diplomatiquement sa vague
de capa étape et il a été convoqué et je
pense que
si le gouvernement pense que c'est la
deuxième étape ils peuvent le faire mais
je ne sais pas encore si c'est là où
yvon mais j bien sûr les discours sont
entraidés c'est du style de toutes parts
est-ce qu'on peut revenir ensemble sur
la reuss urgence du m23 dans l'est de la
rdc comment est ce que vous vous
l'expliquer
premièrement l'avènement du programme de
désarmement démobilisation rémois
communauté stabilisation il me semble
être est la première raison parce que
pour aller passer une occasion de se
faire entendre et essayer de faire
un d'équité des accords de 2013 sous les
couleurs quand il a cessé de
2019 souci c'est qu'il est donc oui je
pense qu'ils ont profité de cette
fenêtre est là pour se faire attendre
aussi pour pousser afin qu'ils soient
prises en compte dans cette nouvelle
dynamique alors même que cette nouvelle
dynamique elle est née à contradiction
avec les précédents diallo parce que
cette fois ci home a décidé qu est il
n'est plus possible de déverser leur
belle d'alarmé nationale donc il y aura
pas possibilité de reconnaître le grade
de ceux qui qui sont dans le groupe
amené ni deux les données de postes et
ça je pense que c'est quelque chose
récisé manquait-il mp3 en plus
précisément les ghanéens mais viril
lorsque la république démocratique du
congo accuse le rwanda voisin de
financer et de soutenir d'armes et le
m23 est ce qu'elle dispose de preuves
matérielles tangibles pour porter ces
allégations
willy à de preuves qui ont été présentés
notamment de militaires qui ont été
arrêtés sous les sols comme l'est encore
peu plus précisément surtout avec la
prise du ghana ma vie de vidéos avec des
militaires qui sont présents sur le
territoire congolais et il ya d'ailleurs
les américains qui aussi confirmé cela
et ils ont d'ailleurs dénoncé la
présence de et de l'armée rwandaise où
les monnaies et justement le fait que
les états unis réagissez et condamne la
présence de forces ou irlandais sur sol
congolais ce que cela veut dire que ce
conflit qui oppose je le rappelle pour
l'heure deux états est en train de
prendre une tournure au delà des
frontières du seul continent africain
absolument je crois que
les états au niveau n 40 international
comment ça réagit enfin sur les discours
sont encore timides le plus des
positions semblent aller dans les
centres et demandé l'apaisement ça
forcément indexé tel ou tel écart c'est
compréhensible mais en même temps il ya
une situation qui peut être explosif
dans do ya nécessité à ce qu'il y ait
plus d'engagement diplomatique mais
aussi peut-être arriver même à des
sanctions ciblées mais il ya des efforts
de médiation menés notamment par le
président en lui un saint lô il ya aussi
des négociations en aérobie et pourtant
il n'y a toujours pas de solution alors
est-ce que la voie diplomatique est
encore une une option à l'heure où les
victimes se succèdent ou deux enfants
ont été tués dans le bombardement de
leur école vendredi dernier
oui je pense que les efforts
diplomatiques sont à saluer
ils se poursuivent hors caméra mais il
est difficile de savoir s'ils vont
aboutir alors qu'elle est disposée
radicalise donc il ya nécessité à ce qu
on parle tous fait est que odh énonce
aussi de
discours qui s'est radicalisée kinect
qui n'aide pas en fait à ce qu'elles ont
pris ce nouvel intérêt d'attendre mais
bien sûr encore aussi on doit exactement
dit les choses telles qu'elles sont et
dénoncé
lé soutien aux groupes armés mais aussi
en fait avoir une idée plus claire des
du retour de la paix dans le congo est
aussi ciblé tous les autres groupes
armés qui continuent à tuer parce que la
compagne du m23 même temps il ya
beaucoup d des victimes qui sont en
train d'être effectués à beni territory
on ne devrait pas oublier d'autres conçu
l'homme des tracés lundi confié à
l'institut comme il y en a d'autres et
qui sont entre des formes des victimes
c'est important on parle merci de le
rappeler en tous les cas merci à vous
régale me dirige rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur au baromètre sécuritaire du
kivu merci d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre aux questions de france 24
le rwanda à destination force et
d'hommes et de femmes en situation
régulière expulsés du royaume uni un
premier vol devait décoller mardi soir
mais l'appareil est toujours cloués au
sol après une annulation à la toute
dernière minute sur décision de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme les
précisions de jules boiteau
sur le tarmac damas brille au royaume
uni cet avion ne décollera finalement
pas toute la journée de mardi de
multiples recours ont été déposés pour
faire annuler les expulsions sur les 130
décidé au départ sept seulement devait
être mené dans la soirée mais quelques
minutes avant le décollage la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
suspendu le renvoi d'un demandeur
d'asile irakien avant que le ministère
de l'intérieur britannique finissent par
annuler le vol
information de dernière minute le
dernier billet est annulée personne ne
part pour le rwanda dans la foulée le
gouvernement britannique a assuré ne pas
vouloir se décourager et faire ce qu'il
faut pour mettre en oeuvre ces
expulsions mais cette annulation sonne
comme un échec cuisant pour le camp du
premier ministre boris johnson depuis
plusieurs jours ses soutiens ont
pourtant martelé leurs détermination à
procéder à ces expulsions vers le rwanda
est essentielle de notre stratégie pour
briser le modèle économique de ces gens
épouvantable ces trafiquants qui font
commerce
les gens payent souvent
validé par la justice britannique
le projet porté par boris johnson vise à
dissuader les demandeurs d'asile arrivés
clandestinement sur le territoire
britannique pour cela le gouvernement
veut les renvoyer à plus de 6000 km de
ses côtes grâce à son partenariat avec
le rwanda très populaire au sein de
l'électorat conservateur la mesure
provoque toutefois un tollé outre manche
les chefs de l'église anglicane dénonce
une politique immorale le prince charles
a lui jugé le projet consternant tout
comme de nombreuses organisations de
défense des droits humains
en cadre de l'organisation état
islamique capturé par les hommes de la
force française barkan l'état major l'a
annoncé aujourd'hui mais les faits
remontent à samedi dernier c'était au
mali est le chef jihadiste a été
interpellées et près de la frontière
avec le niger aux mayas ould-abdallah
c'est son nom était le chef de
l'organisation terroriste al obour ma au
mali et pour l'oudalan lors du burkina
faso
et c'est dans cette zone dite des trois
frontières qu'une nouvelle attaque
terroriste a été menée dans la région
tillabéri précisément c'est dans le sud
ouest du niger au moins huit gendarmes
ont été tués on compte également 33
blessés ce sont les chiffres avancés par
les autorités locales la correspondance
d'harold girard à niamey
huit soldats ont perdu la vie mardi
matin très tôt dans les rangs de l'armée
nigériane lors d'affrontements contre un
groupe armé terroriste dans la région de
tillabéri à 40 km du village de d'argol
contre des dizaines d'hommes en armes
trente trois militaires ont été blessés
parmi eux six le sont gravement et selon
les autorités nigériennes 50 assaillants
présumés terroristes ont été abattus par
l'armée et ses partenaires une seconde
attaque dans la même journée ce même
mardi a eu lieu près du village de tammo
près de la frontière avec le burkina
faso mais pour l'instant pas plus de
précisions sur cette seconde attaque la
dégradation du contexte politique ces
derniers mois au burkina faso continue
de galvaniser l'action terroriste dans
les zones frontalières que ce soit du
côté burkinabè ou du côté du niger par
exemple ce dimanche dans les villages de
c'est un gars la population a subi une
attaque très meurtrière qui a fait près
de 80 morts alors même que le président
nigérien mohamed bazoum continue
d'insister pour que les habitants des
villages des deux côtés de la frontière
déplacés internes ou étrangers rentrer
dans leur localité à la proche de la
saison des pluies pour travailler leurs
terres
à bruxelles en quête d'une alternative
au gaz russe sous forme liquide le
précieux combustible doit être acheminée
depuis israël vers l'egypte avant d'être
expédiés vers l'union européenne en
visite au caire la présidente de la
commission sous la forme de rihanna
s'est félicité de la signature d'un
protocole d'accord en ce sens à plus de
détails avec edward rôle si
pour le moment les contours de cet
accord demeurent floues notamment sur
les quantités de gaz qui seront exportés
mais cela reste un pas important dans
les alternatives au gaz russes frappés
d'un embargo européens décidées au début
du mois de juin en l'état du gaz
israélien sera liquéfié en egypte c'est
le seul pays de la région à pouvoir le
faire et sera ensuite acheminé en europe
ursula von der leyen s'est félicité de
cet accord en pleine crise gazière en
europe tout en appelant à repenser le
système des énergies fossiles en amont
de la coop 27 qui aura lieu en egypte au
mois de novembre
nous sommes actuellement dans un
processus de diversification de nos
fournisseurs en énergie loin des
combustibles fossiles russe à travers de
nouveaux fournisseurs de confiance
et vous êtes ces nouveaux fournisseurs
de confiance vous avez des ressources
naturelles en abondance
vous avez le soleil levant vous avez
potentiellement de l'énergie
hydroélectrique
ce sont les conditions préalables qui
permettront de développer les énergies
propres pour demain
à la suite de cette signature la
présidente de la commission européenne a
rencontré le président si si comme sous
forme d' échange de cet accord elle a
promis 100 millions d'euros pour assurer
la sécurité alimentaire de l'egypte
premier pays importateur de blé au monde
et dont 80% proviennent de russie comme
l'ukraine merci de votre attention se
retrouve dans 45 minutes pour un nouveau
journal de l'afrique d'ici là c'est
audrey racines qui a le plaisir de vous
retrouver
[Musique]